hello if you have found the ideas i
discussed
interesting and useful perhaps you might
consider purchasing my recently released
book beyond order 12 more rules for life
available from penguin random house in
print
or audio format you could use the links
we provide below or
buy through amazon or at your local
bookstore
this new book beyond order provides what
i hope is a productive and
interesting walk through ideas that are
both philosophically and
sometimes spiritually meaningful as well
as being
immediately implementable and practical
beyond order can be read and understood
on its own
but also builds on the concepts that i
developed in my previous books
12 rules for life and before that
maps of meaning thanks for listening
and enjoy the podcast
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased to have with
me today dr
marion l toopy who is the editor
of humanprogress.org
a senior fellow at the center for global
liberty and prosperity
and co-author of the simon project
he specializes in globalization and the
study of global well-being
as well as the politics and economics of
europe and southern africa
his work has been published or featured
in major print and non-print media
outlets
all throughout the english-speaking
world dr toopy received his ba
in international relations and classics
from the university of the wits waters
rand in johannesburg
south africa and his phd in
international relations from the
university of saint andrews
in great britain he is the co-author of
a recent book
10 global trends that every smart person
needs to know
and many other trends you will find
interesting
it's a beautiful book uh and so that's
an accomplishment in and of itself
it's also an extremely interesting book
wide ranging
and necessary in my estimation
partly because most of what we consume
in relationship to global occurrences
economic and otherwise is negative and
that's part of the reason that i wanted
to talk to dr toopey today
because his work is in the same vein as
bjorn lomberg's work and matt ridley's
work
among other people putting forward
stephen pinker putting forward a
narrative of continued and rapid
progress
that seems at odds uh in terms of
content and psychologically with
virtually
everything that seems to make up the
major
media trend story zeitgeist
so welcome dr toopey marion it's really
good to see you
thanks for agreeing to talk to me today
i'm delighted to be with you and uh
welcome back it's great to have you back
in the fight so to speak
thank you i i was really struck to begin
with
by your introduction you talked about
why
you and ronald bailey wrote this book
and so
let's start with that what were you
motivate what did you want to accomplish
with this book and what do you think it
does accomplish
well fundamentally the reality of the
world
the reality of human existence is much
better than
people understand let alone appreciate
[Music]
most people assume that the world is in
a much worse
shape than it really is but the data
points in a different direction it
points in the opposite direction
when you look at long-term trends and we
will talk about some of them
most of them are pointing to
gradual incremental long-term
improvement
now on top of that we live in a world
where a lot of people find meaning and
excitement
in embracing a lot of movements
to quote unquote improve the world
but you cannot improve the world if you
don't
know what the real reality of the world
is
and so if you think the reality of human
existence is different from what really
is
then your improvement can actually
detract from human flourishing
rather than contribute to it so
the idea behind the book was to
inform and
it is not really an attempt to produce a
polyanish
all optimistic view on the world clearly
there are problems that remain and there
will be new problems that will arise
but we believe there is some value in
in in people knowing the facts
factfulness than
that hans rosling used to talk about
and the book is largely
free of theory it is only facts that we
have gotten from
third parties with one exception of a
trend
on natural resources that we will
discuss everything else comes from
uh third sources which are the world
bank the imf
eurostat oecd or well-established
independent and creditable academics
so um and and of course there are
footnotes so that people can check that
we are not trying to deceive them into
anything
and the reason why we structured the
book we did the reason why
we introduced a lot of nice
illustrations is because we wanted to be
a coffee table book of
facts so in addition to all the
architecture books and
books about dogs and cooking that people
put on their
on their dining room tables or living
room tables
uh we are hoping that they will include
this book and so
whilst people are fixing food or drinks
maybe
their guests are going to open the book
and
look at something interesting or
counter-intuitive and maybe that will
lead to a conversation
well it's a book you can sit and read
which
is what i did but it's also clearly a
book that you can leave through
and it it is as i mentioned uh earlier
beautiful so that's an additional
advantage it's a very high quality book
and
that's a nice uh accompaniment to its
essentially
optimistic message um i found
it it interesting overall and also bit
by bit
um you said 10 glo it's it's laid out in
sort of
increasing resolution so you start with
a narrative that
there are reasons to be radically
optimistic about the future
especially when you compare that future
to the past
rather than some hypothetical ideal um
globe at the lowest possible level of
resolution the most general level of
resolution there's reasons to be
optimistic you lay out 10 reasons that
are really profound but then you
differentiate
into a more detailed analysis and i
found that
the details as interesting as the global
trends and
it's really something to be uh
confronted by
something like an unending stream of
positive information and
one thing that that's that's that i
guess two questions sort of naturally
arise out of that is
um why should people believe
this positive narrative that you're
putting forward
given the the undeniable
negativity that seems to be part of our
current view of the world
are speaking broadly and and also seems
to be
something that's constantly pushed in
front of us or consumed by us or
demanded by us
why should we believe that that's wrong
well partly because i think that uh the
most obvious reason is that
people shouldn't believe lies and they
shouldn't believe
wrong stuff people should be well
informed about
all sorts of things they should be aware
of
risks and benefits of individual actions
of what different politicians are
offering
in other words people should seek facts
regardless of the negativity biases
which which we
have in our brains so you know as you
well know being a psychologist
a lot of research has been done on these
negativity biases why do people
prefer to believe the bad news
and one of the reasons is that the bed
is stronger than
good uh it has more emotional impact
it's more memorable as well precisely
the way i like to
think about it is that when i have my
annual review with my boss
you know he can spend 90 of the time
telling me about the things that i've
done
right uh which is always appreciated and
then
also mention some of the things that i
have done wrong and there are always
many
and when i walk out of the interview or
the review
the only thing that's in my mind is
always the criticism
and never the praise and i think that
this is sort of
this applies to to to a lot of people is
that they focus on the slights the
criticisms
rather than the praise i think you see
that with people's use of social media
too if i
scan comments on any given youtube
discussion like this one
it's definitely the case that the
negative comments stick out
and are memorable compared to the
positive comments i mean
i think there is an impact of proportion
so if i see that the vast majority are
positive
and a small minority or negative i can
discount the negative to some degree
but it still has a disproportionate
impact i've thought often that's because
you can be
in extreme pain and dead which is pretty
damn final and so
negative news carries this walloping
potential
impact given our susceptibility to
threat but you can only be
so happy you know there it's not like
there's an infinite amount of happiness
that you can be but there's certainly a
a fine a final amount
of death and pain that you can
experience and so
that that is there any other reasons you
think that
that um like is it is it is it
easy rationale for cynicism and nihilism
for
throwing your hands up in the air and
giving up i mean are there other reasons
that were
we seem so hungry to believe the worst
yes uh before going there let me just
confirm what you said about
social media people who like something
that you have posted
tend to simply click on the love button
or the heart button it's people who
disagree with you that usually leave
the comments saying what a what a
horrible person you are and how bad your
ideas are so
that exacerbates the feeling that um
that
that the feedback is negative yeah there
could be places like twitter too and we
don't know this is that
people are having a bad day and who are
angry
are much more likely to actually leave a
comment or use
twitter for that matter than the same
person even who's having a good day
we just don't know anything about how
these communication technologies
how our emotions affect our use of these
communication technologies
and how that's going to play out in the
future we usually have
a certain time that we need in order to
uh
accumulate to new technologies and
you know we'll see how this one plays
out but we certainly
discovered in use of other technologies
that it took some time before we got
mastery of them cars are a typical
example
people used to have many more accidents
used to speed much more they used to
drink
before driving and it took a while
before before the safety culture set in
and who knows maybe over time people
will leave facebook or
twitter and switch to something else i'm
proud to be facebook free
since 2012 and i don't have a personal
twitter
uh for for processor reason well you do
see
the emotional tenor of of different
social media platforms
does differ i mean i found that
instagram seems to be a much more
positive place
all things considered than twitter it's
a little more complex to use
but it it seems to be less corrosive
i'm not exactly sure why maybe it's
because it's more image heavy
i i don't know exactly possibly
um the the other negativity bias is that
psychologists
have identified is for example the
availability heuristic
as you all know more dramatic and
traumatic events tend to
be revisited in our memory with
greater frequency uh than the positive
memories
and so we get a sense that they are much
more numerous and much more frequent
than they really are also
positive positive things happen over
much longer periods of time
than than negative things
you know it takes years to build a
skyscraper but it takes
hours to pull it down in a terrorist
attack
it takes years to acquire
a lot of human capital through education
but it takes only a second for you to
die in a car crash so
a typical example when it comes to
global well-being would be something
like poverty reduction
as max rosa from oxford university
pointed out
every day over the last goodness knows
how many decades 175
000 people have been raised out of
poverty every day out of absolute
poverty
but those are not the kinds of headlines
that will make it into the newspapers
yeah well right
that's actually it's a threshold issue
too i think they defined absolute
poverty as a dollar ninety a day in two
thousand eleven dollars is that
is that correct dollar ninety two
dollars two oh five uh
people have different one yeah but
around two dollars per person
people slide by that threshold it's also
not a dramatic
decrease in their poverty per person
right because they just move over that
threshold
nonetheless the numbers are very
impressive and actually the speed is
also really impressive i mean we've
decreased our poverty has decreased
absolute poverty has decreased in the
world
at an ever increasing rate that's
accelerated dramatically over the last
15 years and so it also might be that
we just don't know this yet it's it's
it's slow compared to how fast
things can go bad but it's still really
quite rapid
um on on in historical scale
yeah i know that you want to talk about
uh the different trends and one of them
is absolute poverty so maybe we can
return to it in in a moment sure well
let's let's do this then let's go
um tell me just one thing before we get
into this the specific 10 trends
um tell me about human progress.org and
how it is that you come to specialize
in like global well-being i i can't
imagine that there are many people in
the world who have that as a special
as a specialization so tell me about
humanprogress.org and about your
specialization and how that came about
well
my personal story sort of will explain
that i'm
i'm much more interested in westerners
who have
lived a life of relative abundance
good education safety
that they are interested in recognizing
these trends but in my personal case
um the the path to
being interested in well-being is much
more straightforward
i was born behind the iron curtain in
what was
what used to be communist czechoslovakia
and
whilst life wasn't horrible
it was pretty dreadful we can talk about
it some other time
then because my parents are medical
doctors so we moved to
south africa in the early 1990s where
they started practicing
and so i got to travel through a lot of
africa
and there i saw a much worse poverty
and uh and deprivation um and i was
educated in britain
and and i've worked in the united states
so
obviously when you live in four
different cultures
um you if you are at all curious you
have to start
asking yourself how come some countries
are prosperous and some countries
are poor what are the institutional
settings
for the for the production of of riches
after all
at some point in time everybody was
everybody was dirt poor
but now we have large sections of the
world which are escaping from poverty at
a very fast click
whilst others are not doing so well so
that is obviously something that i was
wondering about as i was moving from one
culture to another from one country to
another
and then um at in 2010
i read a wonderful book which is still
worth reading by one of your previous
guests met ridley it's called rational
optimist
and matt ridley's book was filled with
some very interesting
statistics that i didn't know about i
should have known about but i didn't
and i thought to myself well if i don't
know about them and it is my job to know
them
what about the larger public i mean the
general public is surely to be as
ignorant if not more
than i am and so i thought let me put it
up on the website and since then
we have grown to about 1200 different
data sets
and that's really the the story so
that's humanprogress.org
that's humanprogress.org and so is that
that's something you started yourself
yeah i i am i
am an employee of a think tank uh called
uh
the the cato institute but uh uh
the human progress is an autonomous part
of of cato but it runs runs pretty much
autonomously
i have a lot of freedom to do with it
what i want and
but most crucially um the the
information that we provide the
the data itself is completely uh it
comes from third parties
we write articles we write exclusive
articles where we try to frame
the data in the historical context we
try to get into the reasons
why some countries are rich and why some
countries are poor
we can talk about it as well um but we
don't
so we we so we do have an editorial
position when
writing articles and studies we we do
not
play around with the data and anyone who
comes to the website will see the
original data taken from
third sources footnoted sourced and so
on
okay so let me hassle you for a couple
of minutes because i've been
you know i've talked to matt and ridley
and and to bjorn
and so there's a group of people that
are and and stephen pinker for that
matter who are
rational optimists let's say are
intelligent optimists or informed
optimists i got interested in this
i worked for the un for u.n committee
for a couple years and
i was reviewing books by the dozen
on ecology and economics
and i was shocked and what shocked me
was
things were way better than i thought
they were and they were getting better
at a rate that was
stunning and i didn't know any of that
and
it was overwhelming pouring through the
data because i had been so
wrong in my implicit presumptions and so
that's what
got me interested in all of this and of
course i was also extremely happy about
it to see
what was actually happening how many
good things were happening so
but but here's the criticism that that
that so i posted these talks with with
bjorn for example
and you know people have responded often
young people and they say well that's
they say something like this that's all
very well and good for you dr peterson
or
or bjorn you're 50 years old you have a
uh secure position you
grew up when the job market was stellar
um
it's much much harder for young people
to make their way in
in the western world now than it was 20
years ago
that sort of security long-term security
isn't there
and so you can look at these global
trends and
extract out some positive information
from them but
that just gives you license to ignore
the on the ground problems that so many
people so many young people
are either facing or feel that they're
facing in the west and so
what do you think about that what's the
right response to that
i think that young people have had
terrible 20 years
in in western countries we have gone
through uh the 9 11
crisis then followed by the financial
meltdown
we had the iraq war then we had the
covet
pandemic and data shows that
young people specifically seem to be
disproportionately affected and
very unhappy and anxious and so forth
so i would divide it my answer into two
parts the first part is
that it is always
good to uh there's a there's an
economist richard lyman i think his name
is who said always compare yourself
downwards not upwards um in other words
um that that's the cause or rather let's
say
the way to happiness is to compare
yourself downwards rather than upwards
um by that what i gather he meant is
that
even though things are very tough for
young people
young people still have access to the
best health care
in the history of the world they have
access
to more security than any other people
who have come uh before them they have
access
to uh education um
that uh in many cases is free
um and um and plentiful
um and um and so it's important to
realize that while some things
have not been doing well
um there is a lot in terms of
life in in western advanced societies
which is still worth appreciating and
being aware of
the second part please please continue
and the second part of my answer would
be to say
that it is all the more important
for young people to understand
the economic and political reasons
why the west grew at faster rates before
why it had more political and social
stability
before uh than than it is than it
has today young people are very blase on
average
about uh about politics they don't
generally vote
they tend to embrace all sorts of causes
which are inimical
to progress and to growth such as for
example
socialism they tend to be much more open
to it than people who are older and turn
to
turn more conservative and
so delving deeper
into why the 1980s and the 1980s
in the 1990s had higher rates of
economic growth
um it is not a bad idea from the
perspective of young people
well it's also it it
it's also not exactly clear what
baseline is being used when the claim is
made that things
aren't as good or as easy as they once
were i mean they're certainly a lot
better now than they were in 1820.
they're certainly a lot better than they
were in 1930
or 1940 probably 1950
then there was a period of incredible
growth in the 60s in particular the
post-war period where
employment was a relatively
straightforward matter for many people
people and there was plentiful
long-term secure jobs now
how difficult it was in the 60s to
obtain one of those is still an open
question
many people were much less educated than
they are now
um it isn't clear it isn't absolutely
clear to me that things were
any easier any time in the past and it's
certainly the case that
for most of the past things were
immeasurably worse
yeah when i said that they had terrible
20 years what i meant is that the last
20 years almost seemed like a
state of constant crisis but
let's disaggregate this this experience
that young people have
if you are a black person in the united
states for example
um you have never lived
in a safer more tolerant and more
accepting society if you are a gay
person in the world
again uh sorry in western societies you
have never lived in a more tolerant or a
more accepting society if you are a
woman
the same goes for you so that's already
well over 50
of the population also let's not forget
that whilst the wages of certain
people in the united states certain
sections of the labor force have been
stagnating overall the media
the median household income in the
united states
prior to covet was at a record high
which is to say that compared
to the earnings of a median household in
the 1970s or 1980s
american earning power prior to covet
was at an all-time high so it's not true
that people
were poorer now let me
make one last point about this um when
it comes to cost of living in america
which is what a lot of people are
talking about
very much depends on what you are
looking at
cars are cheaper by 70 percent than what
relative to wages than what they were 20
years ago
toys tvs food all of those
are much cheaper than what they were
20 years ago relative to wages even
housing
most people don't know this but it
happens to be true housing in the united
states is 10
cheaper than it was 20 years ago
relative to
wages now that would exclude that would
exclude high demand cities i would
imagine
right that this is this because well
more and more people
want to go to more and more exclusive
and wealthy places
or fewer and fewer exclusive and wealthy
places so that's a complicating like in
toronto
the real estate market housing prices
are just skyrocketing constantly and
my sense of and a lot and my sense of
that is that
there's 20 cities in the world that are
optimal places to live so they're
they're scarce
and this is one of them and and people
are quite mobile and there's quite a lot
of money and so
that drives real estate prices here
continually upward and you see that in
new york you see that in
the major european cities that are
highly desirable you see that in san
francisco
but there aren't many places like that
so that's part of the reason for that
that's absolutely right both things
happen to be true at the same time
the 10 percent decline in the prices of
housing is average
across the united states whereas in the
high demand areas it has also
skyrocketed now
now in some places like for example uh
manhattan where a lot of young people
want to live
there is only so much that you can do in
order to provide
additional housing because it's an
island however
in many other places in the united
states um
housing is artificially restricted the
building of new housing is artificially
restricted through nimbism
through zoning rules and and so forth
yeah i see it we don't allow you to be
poor here you can't afford it it's
against the law because of the zoning
laws and that's a real problem in places
like san francisco
and and the two areas which
have seen a massive appreciation in
price well above
inflation well above um
well above wages is health care and
education
so right now right right and education
is a particular burden for young people
right and now would it be crazy of me to
suggest
that young people instead of blaming the
market or asking for
you know free education looked at the
reasons why
education is so expensive could it be
that because governments push
so much money out of the door through
pell grants
and other heavily subsidized loans
the universities know they can charge
much more money than would otherwise be
the case could that be the reason why
education is is um increasing the price
could it be though
i also think the universities in some
sense have conspired
to rob their students of their future
income
well look imagine that you come to a
car store and
there's just one car left and you say to
the salesman
i really really really have to have this
particular car
this would be yale harvard
whatever and by the way
i have a million dollars in my pocket
how much is the car salesman going to
ask you
the million dollars and it's a very
similar
situation when it comes to higher
education the universities know exactly
how much the parents are making
they know exactly how much money you can
get out of government in
in loans so of course they're going to
jack up the prices
and in healthcare what's happening of
course is that only 10
out of every 90 cents spent on health
care in the united states
is spent by people themselves by the
patients themselves the rest is spent by
governments at different levels of
governance
it's spent by third parties by
insurance companies so when you walk
into a uh
you know into a doctor's office and he
asks you
or you know do you want to have 10 or 20
blood tests
you said 20 i'm not paying for it anyway
and that's part of the reason again why
uh healthcare has
exploded in but between those two
i can see why americans would be quite
dissatisfied with their standards of
living and i'm afraid that
a third reason why americans are going
to be dissatisfied with their standards
of living is coming
down the pipeline and i think that is
going to be a massive increase
in energy costs in the united states
just as it happened in europe in europe
now
they have they have a term called energy
poverty so even in places which are the
height of economic development like
britain and germany people are not
heating their homes in the middle of
winter
people are washing themselves in
lukewarm water because prices of energy
have been artificially
by government fear jacked up to prices
where even the richest people in the
world
i mean as a population not as a share of
population cannot afford
things which are the essence of what
life should be like in a western
civilization and what worries me
is that some of those proposals that
i've taken taken on
in europe and which are making europeans
so miserable are going to come down to
the united states and perhaps even to
canada
okay so let's let's draw some quick
conclusions and then we'll go
talk about the 10 major trends and so
correct me if i
if i've got any of this wrong um
it's very difficult to make an informed
case that things are worse now
in almost every way than they were at
any other time in the past at any time
in the past including the last two
decades but certainly going back
before that things are better on almost
every possible measure
people don't know that partly because we
have a negativity bias we're attracted
by negative information and that's what
put that's what
is put forth by a media hell-bent on
attracting our attention at any cost
we're also deluded to some degree by our
historical ignorance
and also by anomalies in the
economic scheme exceptionally high
prices of housing in high
high demand high quality areas high
and the same thing happening say with
university education despite the fact
that maybe state
university education is still quite
cheap or community college that kind of
thing
um
and and and and then there's this
there's also this because because of
this pervasive
negative uh message that's being put
forward constantly
that also encourages us to exaggerate
the degree to which the current
condition is uh bad and getting worse
we don't know and we assume that and
that makes us more miserable than we
have
any reason to be the danger in that is
that we're going to
fail to appreciate and work to undermine
all sorts of things that are
actually working very well if we only
could see
the the the facts on the ground
that's exactly right and if there is one
message that i would like to pass
on to your young followers who who are
having a tougher time than would be
expected for young people to have
um things could get much worse if
uh the the the basic
underpinnings of what made western
society
rich and prosperous which is to say
liberal the
liberal democracy and some form
of free market capitals and free
enterprise if those two
are eroded uh or destroyed
we are in for a much tougher time if you
want to see how young people
how a society can deteriorate go to
venezuela
you know it's not that far away it's a
couple of hours from miami
and see how young people live there now
venezuela
was a country where in the early 1950s
gdp per capita was higher
than in the united states higher than in
the united states
today people are eating cats and dogs
and slaughtering animals in zoo for meat
um young women have no other option but
to prostitute themselves to slay
to to prostitute themselves men have
gone into crime it is basically a failed
society
not long ago some of the leading lights
of
american of american progressivism
such as aoc have been uh
in canada have been singing the praises
of
21st century venezuela socialism so
um so things could get much worse and
they will
if uh if if if we forget
the lessons of history and if we don't
understand
that the the political stability to the
effect
to the extent we still have it is a
result of liberal democracy
limited government and the the outcome
and the reason for economic growth and
the reason why we have all the nice
things that people in venezuela don't
is because we have free markets free
enterprise
um and um and free trade
okay okay let's let's uh
well you'd also think it's kind of
strange that given our proclivity
let's say to devour bad news you'd think
that the story of venezuela would get a
lot more coverage than it actually gets
so that's kind of weak maybe we can
return to that let's go through the
trends here
so the first one so the book is
structured so that on the right hand
page there's a graphic graph
showing progress across time time or
change across time a variety of
different
trends let's say the first one the first
trend is
the great enrichment and uh
tell us what that means and and what it
signifies
so the chart which you may be able to
show at some point in the future looks
like a hockey stick
which is to say that for all of our
recorded history
let's say going back 4000 bc but we can
estimate
even even further back in time there it
is the hockey stick of human prosperity
um the the line has flatlined uh it is
estimated that prior to
the industrial revolution in the uh late
17 and early 1800s
um global economy grew by about
0.1 per year which is to say
that to double your prosperity would
have taken thousands of years
um as late as 1900
which is to say the presidency of
theodore roosevelt
queen victoria was on the throne the
the globe produced roughly three
trillion dollars
in output um i i i
this is all inflation-adjusted so three
trillion dollars in output the entire
globe
in 2018 it was 121 trillion dollars
so from 3 trillion to 121 trillion
dollars
in a scope of 100 years adjusted for
inflation
and if the growth that we have
experienced
the growth rate that we have experienced
over the last 100 years
continues into 2100
the world will produce 600 trillion
dollars in output real
inflation-adjusted output
over the next 80 years the globe could
produce
six times more value than it is
currently producing
if we maintain the current economic
growth rate and do you think that's an
optimistic projection or a conservative
projection
that's what leads us back to the
original point that we discussed it very
much depends on economic policies and
political stability
um if you don't have civil wars around
the world
then and and government change hand
in a peaceful and predictable way um
then we should be okay when it comes to
political stability
when it comes to economics we are seeing
as
surprising and uh to be quite frank
well to be frank surprising and almost
inexplicable
um renewed interest
in uh more restrictive economic policies
uh from socialism on the left
to hardcore protectionism on the right
and and if our economic growth rate
falls from 1.82
that we have experienced over the last
year to
zero point one percent which we have
experienced over the previous ten
thousand years
then it will take us six thousand years
to get from one
100 trillion dollars to 200 trillion
dollars
so the so the most remarkable thing
about this is is
is exactly the hockey stick shape it's
as you pointed out
nothing at all happened until eight the
mid-1800s essentially and then all of a
sudden
things improved so rapidly that it's
virtually incomprehensible
it's it's it's a miracle it is the most
important question in economics
um what happens in the late 1700s early
1800s
that produces that hockey stick effect
and just to clarify
there have been in human history periods
of
economic ef fluorescence flourishing
but they were usually restricted to
small parts of the world
and they were usually they usually
petered out so for example song
china has produced some remarkable
um technological discoveries and it
appeared to be
at a time of relative plenty compared to
other countries in the world
but that petered out when song song
dynasty was replaced by the ming dynasty
similarly the roman empire appears to
have been a place that was
largely at peace internally and quite
prosperous
but that came to an end in uh 467 or
whenever that happened
uh when when when rome fell so there are
these periods
uh that you can have prosperity also
let's stay with europe i mean europe has
experienced
the greatest century of peace and
prosperity between 1814
the end of napoleonic wars and 1914 the
breakout of the first world war
which slaughtered tens of millions and
destroyed
a lot of wealth so you know
economic progress can certainly take a
knock
and it can take a time to to recover but
in order for it to recover you have to
rediscover the reasons why
you had high economic growth rates in
the first place
so okay so the first lesson is that
something happened
in the last 150 years that propelled
human productive capacity and
distribution
globally into the stratosphere
and there's no sign that that's slowing
um although we could disrupt it and we
could disrupt
it because we don't exactly understand
why it happened and
we're not appreciative enough of the its
miraculous nature and the
perhaps fragile preconditions for its
continued existence well when i said
that it's the biggest question in
economics
i i'm not suggesting that there aren't
theories of why it happened in theory
the theory that i
espoused and the theory that has
convinced me
is that over hundreds of years
in western europe and in north america
and then later in other parts of the
world
our economic and political institutions
have grown more inclusive
open or to use a political word liberal
now i'm using liberal in its european
sense
not liberal in the current american
and what that meant was that you no
longer needed
a permission from the king in order to
open a shop or
import a bag of wool from another
country so there's an autonomy
there's an element of autonomy but
there's also an element of generosity
that that autonomy leads to increased
productivity but the product the
consequences of the production are also
being shared
and rather than hoarded they're being
distributed reasonably well
um yes but the key here was i think that
monarchies uh governments have become
uh have become more
responsible to their people more
accountable to their people
and they started allowing a much greater
level of economic freedom
now the reason why that happened is a
very interesting one once again i'm
going to tell you a theory that i
espouse and theory that convinced me
other people may have other ideas but
basically what has happened
is that unlike in other parts of the
world such as the ottoman empire and
such as
china europe never had
an an internal empire one dynasty
was never able to conquer um different
european states into
the creation of one european mega empire
and because governing elites of
different states
france uh germany spain
portugal holland belgium whatever
because they wanted to survive because
they didn't want to be
vassals of another monarch because they
wanted to remain
independent they realized that they
needed to generate a lot of economic
growth internally
and they realized that the only way that
they could generate economic growth
was through technological innovation and
technological innovation you can only
get into in societies
which allow people a greater degree a
relatively great degree
of intellectual freedom and so
countries which felt at most threatened
such as holland
because the french were always trying to
take them over
would welcome into their cities and into
their
uh into the country um
thinkers from all over the world free
thinkers from all over europe
who establish themselves there produce
new ideas produce new technologies and
holland could defend
itself against the predation of other
countries england was another example
of of how this happened so
it is through geopolitical competition
in other words the
dismemberment of european countries
um that that you get
greater appreciation of the need for
freedom
which then leads to innovation which
then leads to generation of more
money which then can keep your country
independent and from being
swallowed by a foreign by a foreign
conqueror
but if you want to reduce it to one
sentence it would be
political and economic institutions
became more open inclusive and liberal
whether you were a jew
or whether you were a muslim or a
christian or a catholic
you could function within the amsterdam
stock exchange and
nobody uh and you were free from
prosecution
all right let's go to the next trend the
end of poverty
and that's this graph
before the industrial revolution or
rather let's start 12 000 years ago when
humanity discovers agriculture
between two 12 000 years ago and
roughly 200 years ago pretty much
everybody in the world
was a farmer or a farm laborer
as late as 1800 roughly 9 out of 10
people
around the world were involved in
agriculture they were farmers
and they were very poor and then
the other 10 percent were basically the
nobility the clergy and the military
but but 90 of humanity were either
remained hunter-gatherers or they were
farmers or farm laborers
and then with the industrial revolution
you start factoring opening up
all over the western world and people
realize that they can make more money in
the cities working in factories so they
start leaving
leaving the rural areas and moving into
urban areas
earning more money and eventually the
agricultural population in the united
states for example declines from forty
percent in nineteen hundred
well from ninety percent in eighteen
hundred to forty percent
in uh nineteen hundred to two percent
today
today only two percent of american
workers work in agriculture the rest of
them
works in uh in uh
in you know services industry tourism
computing and whatever but this is a
process through which americans
stopped being very poor and became very
rich and this process is repeating
all around the world the world is
industrializing the world is becoming
more service oriented
and fewer and fewer people around the
world work in agriculture even though
our agricultural output is higher than
ever before and we'll get to that trend
too
so just to just just to highlight the
meaning of this graph
so in 1830 95
of the global population was in absolute
poverty that was
a much smaller number of people as well
and
by the year 2015 roughly speaking we're
down to 10 percent
it's stunning and the change from 1990
to 2010
is approximately 40 to approximately
to approximately 10. so that's right
and you see what partly i think what
happened you tell me if you think this
is right or wrong but
this there's been a real acceleration in
the decline of absolute poverty let's
say since 1990 and
not coincidentally it was at
approximately that time that the soviet
union collapsed and so one of the major
competitive systems whose advantages
were touted in the developing countries
for example was no longer a major player
and it was
a little bit after that that china
started to liberalize at least
economically even though it really
hasn't done it politically
and and so i think that's at least
partly responsible for the acceleration
in the reduction of absolute poverty
the decline in uh socialism communism
the basically the disappearance of
socialism at least for a little bit of
time
as an alternative and widely accepted
way to
riches meant that developing countries
changed their developing strategies
beginning in the 1980s
they started opening up more instead of
seeing multinational corporations as
parasites and enemies they started
welcoming them into their own countries
instead of rejecting foreign direct
investment they started opening up to
foreign direct investment
so at a time when globalization starts
really in 1980 or so
at the time of when ronald reagan
becomes president of the united states
of the world live in absolute poverty
that declines to about 30
by the new millennium and from the new
millennium
to today 20 years it declines from 30
to less than 10 percent so you're
absolutely right the decline in poverty
has accelerated over the last 20 years
from 30 percent
to uh less than 10 percent
it's stunning it's absolutely stunning
it's absolutely unbelievable
that that can be the case it is the
fastest reduction
in in global poverty primarily
because uh many poor and previously
socialist countries have changed
their understanding of economics and way
to prosperity
i wanted i want to harass you again
about something so you were talking
about socialism and its decline
um
so canada's has many democratic
socialist
policies norway which in your book
uh ranks highest in terms of the human
development index i believe that's
that's the case
um the scandinavian countries of course
are famous for
functional democratic socialism and so
what do you think what what do you have
to say about that forget about
communism and the hardcore communist
soviet-pushed
maoist doctrines that anyone with any
sense is going to regard
in the light of what happened
historically as absolutely
counterproductive
anyone who supports maoist doctrines or
soviet doctrines
is reprehensible in my they're so
ignorant
or malevolent in some sense that it's
reprehensible
it gets more complicated i would say
when you're talking about
um the range of redistributive policies
that that characterize northern europe
and central europe and canada and the
united states there's a
wide range of of of
theories preferences for government
intervention and for socialist
democratic socialist policies and so
how much of how much of a range do you
think there is
where where where
the left and the right are equally
functional but but emphasize different
things that
that might be the way of thinking about
it right you are certainly
correct on china which is abandoned
which is abandoned hardcore communism in
the late 1970s
but india was never communist but even
they reformed in the early 1990s and
embraced a much freer economic model and
that's 1.2 billion people so that also
explains why the global
poverty rate uh has declined
now you're raising a very important
point and that there is a difference
between uh socialism which is uh
government ownership of the means of
production factories and whatever
and social democracy in europe
in places like denmark norway
sweden and even perhaps canada but
here's the interesting thing
all of these countries come at the very
top of the economic freedom of the world
report which is published by the fraser
institute in in canada you may be
familiar
with them so it is actually possible to
measure
economic freedom in different countries
and fraser has been doing so since the
early
1970s and all of these countries
um all these social democratic countries
actually scored very well
here is the reason why first of all they
have
very flexible labor markets
second they have very described define
that define that
so everyone understands meaning uh the
ability of firing
and hiring people is lightly regulated
so that people can move from industries
and occupations which are
maybe unproductive or
[Music]
which are unproductive into into
wherever uh
the there is a new uh company that's
opening
uh you you don't suffer consequences so
things are allowed to die and be born
precisely the second reason why they are
scoring very high on the economic
freedom of the world report
is because they are open to foreign
trade they are actually
more open to foreign trade than the
united states which is supposed to be a
paragon
of capitals and although obviously the
united states isn't but they are very
free trade oriented
and also if you look at their tax
structure what you realize that
they actually have very low corporate
tax rates
so as opposed to say the united states
which is one of the highest corporate
tax rates in the world
so what the scandinavians and the social
democrats have discovered is
roughly speaking the following let's
keep the economy free let's try to
generate as much
revenue through economic growth and then
tax that do not tax the productivity of
the worker and of the company
in terms of uh corporate tax rates
uh or rather let's let's try to
um let's try to have an open economy and
generate economic growth by
by by producing and by being a welcoming
area for for new businesses to open
okay okay well we'll return to that
are we running out of resources trend
three
that's this graph so just remember that
green
orange and blue line because i will
describe them one by one
so this is the only datum or set of data
which
i produced myself together with a
co-author gail pulley from hawaii
and what it shows is the average price
of
50 most important natural resources
between 1980 and
2018 and what we found
as you would expect is they increased in
nominal price
nominal price is unadjusted for
inflation as everybody know or should
know
currency becomes less valuable every
year because more of it is printed
so in terms of nominal dollars the 50
commodities have become
more expensive over the last 40 years
once you adjust
the cost of commodities and i'm talking
about
oil gas chicken beef
lumber shrimp oranges whatever
once you account for inflation that was
the orange line
what you see is actually the natural
resources are much cheaper today
than they were in 1980.
the final line is the blue line the blue
line is what i call the time price
time price is really uh
it's a better price than than
than real or inflation adjusted price
because it also takes into account wages
as you know wages tend to increase
above inflation because people become
more productive so if if inflation in
the united states is two percent
a typical increase will be maybe about
three percent because people have become
more productive over the course of the
year
so when you once you start comparing
prices of resources relative to
relative to wages what you see that they
have fallen
even more and why is this
counter-intuitive they felt by about 70
in terms of in terms of uh time prices
all the while and that's from 1980 to
2016.
or 16 or 18 uh one over 18. okay so
despite
despite more people despite more
urbanization
despite the hypothetically decreasing
prevalence of resources
despite all of those hypothetical
problems
there's been a 70 decline in basic
global commodity prices
adjusted for wages from 1980 till
2018. stunning right not what anyone was
predicting in the 1960s by any stretch
of the imagination
yes that's absolutely correct so even
though the population of the world has
increased by something like 70 percent
uh the prices of natural resources have
declined by 70
which means that every additional person
born
on the planet has made things cheaper
for us by about one
percent and nobody saw that coming um
right that should be said 50 times right
because it's so
it's so not what anyone thinks more
people
means more wealth that's exactly right
and
you know i've also seen that more people
means more ecological preservation and
so does more wealth because richer
people care more about the environment
and
and so you see that perverse uh
occurrence too that as
g once gdp gets to the point where
people aren't scrabbling around
trying to stay alive so maybe five
thousand dollars per capita
all of a sudden environmental concerns
start to manifest themselves and so it
looks like
we could have more people and make them
richer faster and that would be better
for the planet
no that's absolutely right the cleanest
environment in the world is
in uh advanced countries uh in in
western uh capital societies
when you when you see tremendous attack
on on the environment
is in poor countries uh you know when
the venezuelan
economy collapsed they started eating
animals in zoo
in zimbabwe when their economy collapsed
they started slaughtering the wildlife
you know if it's a choice between
killing a giraffe or having my baby die
i know what i have to do right um but
so so for the longest time um
people thought that if if population
grows
we are going to run out out of resources
and this is not what has happened
we have more resources resources are
cheaper but that in itself is an
indication that they are more abundant
than than before
because of course human beings are not
just consumers of resources we're not
just destroyers of resources we also
creators of resources
human beings are producers of ideas yes
and on average we produce more than we
consume otherwise we would die well
that's exactly right and that's what
people like thomas maltos or poor auric
paul ehrlich at stanford university were
worried about they freaked out
two generation of two generations of
people our league's population and we
still haven't we still haven't recovered
from that
but we still haven't recovered from that
apocalyptic narrative no one believes if
i tell my students
we're going to peak at 9 billion and we
can handle that and then the population
is going to decline
no one believes that if if you say that
well we've got richer as more people
have been born rather than poor because
brain power exceeds uh consumption
essentially
especially as people have got healthier
and and their iq has increased which is
something we could talk about as well
um none of this is part of the general
uh apocalyptic narrative
no not only can we get access to new
resources but also we can replace
resources which
which are becoming scarce so for example
um
humans used to make candles out of
spermachetti which is this
weird
sort of stuff in in the brains of
oils the oil in fat
in in the brains of the whales so we
used to murder them
um by the thousands and we used to
scrape out that spermachetti and
build it into into nice candles and
then we realized that we didn't have to
do that that it was actually quite
expensive and quite stupid because we
could produce electricity by burning
coal and then we decided that we can
switch from coal
from coal to gas and maybe eventually to
to to nuclear
whatever and and and and
so that's how humanity manages
to uh constantly produce more it's
through
innovation and in fact in western
countries today
we are we have reached peak stuff this
is a book
very important book which i recommend to
your readers by andrew mcafee
uh and that is uh making uh more from
less or more from less
um now what it means really is that even
though
the american economy and the british
economy continue to
grow and produce more gdp per capita
in absolute terms the amount of
resources that go into it be it a
bit aluminum or or
whatever that has actually peeked off
about 10 or 20 years ago and it's now
declining
so we have become so incredibly
productive
that we can now use much less resources
in order to produce more wealth more gdp
and four peak population
peak population so right now there are
7.8 billion people
in the world it looks like we are going
to
peak at 9.8 in the 2060s or the 80s
and then it will decline to about 8.8 by
the end of this century
lancet um had a study a couple of months
ago which showed
again remember 7.8 billion people in the
world today
landsat thinks that there will be either
6.8 or 8.8 billion people in the world
in 2100
but uh but every every demographer
uh that i know of expects that human
population will peak
and then it will start declining that's
because um a total fertility rate which
is to say the number of babies
born to a woman uh have been on a
downward trajectory
currently in the united states in much
of western europe
women are having fewer than two babies
per woman per lifetime and in order to
have a replacement rate
you need 2.1 babies because some of them
die
so uh population uh without immigration
in western europe will continue to
decline um
uh our numbers are still going up
because obviously we have
a huge uh huge immigration but but but
women are not having that many babies
now is this going to be a blessing or is
it going to be a
a potential problem well it could be a
potential problem
because because uh human beings are the
producers of ideas and ideas lead to
innovation
and uh if a genius is one out of a
billion or one out of a million
then the fewer millions of people you
have born the fewer geniuses are going
to be born
and that in itself and and
that that to me is a is a major concern
but of course
in western countries we have promised so
much
to the future generations that are
supposed to that are supposed to be paid
for
by uh by by children who are born in the
future
that if those children are not being
born who is going to pay off that debt
in the future who's going to pay for all
those retirees
those questions should also be answered
yes it's quite surprising to note that
one of the more pressing social problems
in 100 years
might be that there aren't enough people
rather than too many could easily be the
case
right so by by then perhaps we'll have
robotics uh to help us a lot um
you know take yes and who knows right we
can't even think about problems 100
years in the future because it's going
to be so different 100 years from now
that nothing we could possibly talk
about
right now is going to be relevant god
only knows we can't we can't
we don't have a five-year horizon or a
10-year horizon given the rate of
technological change
let alone 100 years so but that the
moral of this story is
um it doesn't look like we're going to
overpopulate
the planet to the point where we're
going to destroy all our natural
resources
the planet and everyone's going to
starve that doesn't seem to be
in the cards so unless we make
catastrophic and
likely avoidable errors that's correct
all right next this is a great
headline the end of famine
so um i think it was in ridley's book i
found
uh his last one or maybe in the rational
optimist
famine was quite widespread in europe in
the 20th century
far more than people generally remember
realize i mean holland went through
terrible famines
the scandinavian countries and uh of
course in great britain in the late
1800s the the irish
famine haunted was a specter that
haunted the entire world's population
until extraordinarily recently and the
news on that front is
astoundingly positive no one starves
anymore
except for political reasons essentially
so forced starving planned starvation
but not accidental
so that's correct so in the late 1800s
we
started understanding um
agriculture and agricultural
productivity much more
than before not only did we introduce
new technologies
uh better plows and so forth but we also
discovered that guano which is just bird
pooping uh bird poop
from south america uh contain
so many nutrients especially phosphorus
that when it was sprinkled
all over um the the late
night the late 19th century um
agricultural land it could actually
increase yields tremendously
uh and then when we started running out
of guano yet another example of human
ingenuity we started producing synthetic
fertilizers full of i believe it's
nitrogen and phosphorus and so forth now
that wasn't the last when it came to
human ingenuity we started also toying
with
the genes of different plants which led
to a new sturdier
and more productive wheat
varieties in the 70s by a man called
john burlock john burleigh right who
saved
more people than any other person who
ever lived
in all likelihood that's exactly right
so instead it's quite interesting that
just as people were starting to be
really worried about
this population growth especially in
china and india
uh people immediately started working on
uh the ways to to solve use to solve the
problem and so
you know the population bomb comes out
in 1968
and right about that time into the early
70s
you have borlaug introducing these new
varieties wheat varieties into
bangladesh and india and china and
elsewhere and of course
food production rockets skyrockets india
today is a major
exporter of food now these people who
are starving by tens of millions
when i was growing up in the 1980s i
remember being terrified by the images
of
starving people starving children in in
east
africa in in in the horn of africa um
and now you see this is so um
unbelievable
the world's poorest region sub-saharan
africa
now enjoys access to food in volumes
that are equivalent to portugal in the
1960s
so now it's in that's a very a very
small amount of time
from the 1960s to now well within living
memory of many people
the one of the richest countries in the
world had
the same amount of food per capita as
the poorest part of the world does now
stunning stunning absolutely remarkable
and so positive so good yeah so today
um access to calories in africa is
roughly 2 400
calories per person per day uh now
obviously not everybody gets it there
are serious problems
in africa still you do still have
conflict and so forth and people do get
to starve
but the widespread starvation because
you couldn't produce enough food that
doesn't happen
anymore and that's obviously a
tremendously positive
uh step forward in fact uh many african
problems
uh many african countries are beginning
to experience the problem of obesity
especially in urban centers now if
somebody told you that
50 years ago you would have you would
have said you know you're high
right so the problem in a hundred years
is that um
we're going to have nothing but fat
people and there'll be far too few of
them
[Laughter]
yeah okay next one this is also stunning
shocking
completely unexpected more more
land for nature who would have possibly
guessed that
i read something the other day too and
we could comment on this
the sahara desert has shrunk by eight
percent
since the millen turn of the millennium
we we've greened an additional ten
percent of the earth's surface
as a consequence
that's part of the same development and
that's only over the last 20 years
20 years and it looks like it's a
consequence of increased carbon dioxide
perversely enough the sahara has
actually shrunk
so i don't want to get into the carbon
dioxide argument but this is
this is a whole different issue here
tree cover loss gain
from 1982 to 2016. so
comment on that yes i mean one of the
things is that
one of one of the benefits of getting a
little bit older
uh perhaps on the only benefit of
getting it all is that one gets
wiser and one one remembers all the
stuff
that we used to believe and take for
granted which
have never happened and which were false
uh one of them was the the the expansion
of sahara
in the 1980s i remember being absolutely
terrified that sahara was going to
expand and swallow the globe we you know
as kids we were taught that as gospel
um but sahara is shrinking it is also
true
that there is more foliage which is more
greenery
plants are producing more foliage
because of the co2 in the atmosphere
co2 is for another discussion but but
the fact is that
it's the basic fact of living on earth
that plants
like more co2 in the atmosphere it's
their food which is why
norway grows uh you know tomatoes in hot
houses that are filled with co2
precisely because they want
them to grow and and so
so plants like co2 and foliage is
increasing
but also the tree coverage of the world
is increasing
between i wrote this statistic down or
thinking that we might talk about it
between 1982 and
2016 we have added
trees uh tree area the size of
alaska and montana combined to the world
now that's a pretty big chunk of the
world
uh the united states has 35 percent more
trees than when ronald reagan
become president of the united states
china 35
no china is 15 yeah okay so now i've
read critiques of this too
when i've tweeted this for example
people say yes but
we've lost a tremendous amount of
biodiversity that many of the
much of the much of the new growth is
monoculture
in contrast to the previous growth and
um
i suspect that's not true in some
situations and is true in others i don't
think that's true of the reforestation
of
of the united states but but i don't
know do you know
well first of all compared to what at
the time
when industrial revolution started in
great britain
which is which was responsible for many
of the great things that happened since
then
at that time one of the reasons why they
had to switch to coal
is because there was no tree left in
britain i'm exaggerating but
i am not far off um the
the tree coverage in britain was just
completely
deluded of of forests over
millennia of forest destruction remember
trees were not only needed to keep you
warm but to cook your food to make your
furniture to make your carriages
to make your weaponry everything prior
to the modern era was based on trees
i'm exaggerating but not too much trees
now so compared to what
we have destroyed a lot of we have
destroyed a lot of the natural forest
with its original biomass
a long time before the industrial
revolution which by the way used up uh
called no trees
um but but
today most of our tree usage
comes from the new forests the forests
that are planted
for the specific purpose of being cut
down for lumber
which then builds american and canadian
houses
it is very rare that uh the the sort of
wood that you see in the shops or that
goes into productive activity actually
has originated in the brazilian
rainforest
right so i guess the the objection would
be those aren't forests they're crops
they just happen to be crops of trees
and i suppose and you know biodiversity
loss is obviously
problematic and even potentially
catastrophic but
i don't think that means that you can't
take heart
about the fact that much more of the
planet is green and there's a certain
amount of reversion to a more natural
habitat certainly indicator that we're
much more efficient
users of resources we don't have to take
up so much space and
the agricultural revolution also
contributed to that to a great degree
that's human engineered again because
we can grow more on less land and i
don't see that stopping i think we're
going to get more and more and more
efficient at food production
why would that stop the market
certainly drives us in that direction
and there's no indication of that
slowing as far as i can tell
so three points i hope i can remember
them uh one is
uh yes because of increased agricultural
productivity we are already returning
land to nature and when we can do so
in the future at an increased
pace which means that we are land we are
we are returning land
not just to the animals but we are
returning it to nature where the
biomass can uh can grow again and where
it can reconstitute itself
um the second point is that
we are also living in a world that has
record acreage
and mileage and square mileage of
globe's territory
which is protected from any kind of
interference from humankind
so we have we have record
square mileage of oceans which are now
protected and which cannot be fished in
and we have square mileage of
land which
[Music]
which is protected in national parks or
is otherwise
uh excluded from economic activity
the third point that i want and and that
comes with wealth
the wealthy countries they are and
stability and political stability
because
you you don't need much catastrophe and
social breakdown before those national
parks and all their animals are going to
have everything
eaten out of them typical example would
be
zimbabwe yes and the last point i want
to make is that
we have a problem in brazil brazil has
obviously vast rainforests and very
ancient forests
which are filled with all sorts of
things that
we may discover are helpful to us in the
future we
you know um as well as dangerous but
nonetheless uh
very few people would say that that it's
a good thing to get rid of the brazilian
rainforest
my understanding is and i'm i'm
willing to be proven wrong on this is
that most of it has to do
with farming especially of poor people
in
in brazil who burn forests in order to
clear the land for agricultural activity
now i realize that this point will may
not necessarily be appreciated by
wealthy people in the west but poverty
in developing countries can be
very very bad in brazil
there are some pockets of real wealth
but there are also pockets of tremendous
poverty and the more
inland you get and the more into the
amazon you get
the poorer the people become these
people
from their perspective and the
perspective of their government should
be allowed
to earn a living the way you protect
amazon
is is to have higher grade rates of
economic growth in brazil
so that those people start moving away
from the amazon they start moving to
cities like sao paulo and rio de janeiro
and others
and they start working there in the
factories in the service industry
and they no longer have to burn forests
in order to plant food
so they don't starve
number seven trend seven planet
city urbanization
which you also regard and describe as a
net
positive well you certainly get the
synergistic effect of bringing people
together right i mean look at san
francisco the silicon valley
the urbanization of a genius population
that produces an incredible amount of
innovation
so urbanization everyone's moving to the
cities
um yeah i think that right now we have
about 55
of humanity living in the cities already
so again
all those people are obviously not
living on land which is which is a good
thing
you remember paul pott right cities are
parasites on the countryside
and should be eradicated well that
turned out to be spectacularly wrong in
every possible way as well as murderous
so it's a good thing for people to leave
their rural environments and move to the
city
good thing all things concerned so sorry
continue
at least no no no i i think uh paul pott
yeah i mean didn't he also shoot all
people with spectacles
because they were intellectuals oh yeah
he was trained after sorbonne
well okay right say no more
that's great i i think he still holds
the record
for uh most people killed as a share of
the population
i think he managed to kill what one
third or one quarter of the population
in four years
i don't think anybody has done that even
even marvel
uh it's a hell of a record to hold
and it's quite appalling that he was
trained in the west it's stunningly
appalling
so okay back to organization i
i i feel that we have bashed the french
enough here
maybe not enough but anyway the um
so yes there are the network and
synergetic effects of people
living close together and exchanging
ideas and
and similar companies existing next to
each other communicating and so forth
uh generates more economic growth and
look the historical record is absolutely
clear
cities have been the drivers of progress
whether it is amsterdam in the 17th
century or london
sorry 18th century or london in 19th
century new york in the 20th century
um that's where stuff happened not just
in terms of economic growth but also in
terms of culture um
and and and things like that so
and the final point uh cities
also um consume less energy than urban
areas per capita
because we have public transport people
don't have to drive their jeeps and and
four by fours wherever they go with
long distances um so uh
people consume less energy in in cities
per capita and that said that's a
that's again a good thing i think and is
that controlling for agricultural
productivity even
do you know um i don't
know i think uh
co2 i think co2 emissions and energy
consumption is smaller in the cities
than it is in the rural areas but
but i i that's all i remember from that
particular passage okay
okay trend eight democracy on the march
that's a graph of autocracies versus
democracies
so this uh particular chart
um is controversial one you know partly
because it keeps on changing
in in directions which me we may not
necessarily appreciate
um it is undeniable
that the world is most democratic
than the last decade in the world has
been most democratic in
that than than at any time before in the
last few years
we have seen weakening of democracy we
have seen some countries which have
turned away from
democracy to dictatorship such as for
example uh
russia um you know there are some
authoritarian tendencies even in europe
in places like in places like hungary
nonetheless nonetheless
greater share of humanity lives
in under a democratic regime than say in
uh
30 years ago 60 years ago 100 years ago
and so forth and and the big
wave of democratization really happens
after the collapse of the soviet union
in 1991
and of course the collapse of the berlin
wall in 1989
after that you see basically before then
there were more autocracies than
democracies in the world and after the
fall of soviet union you had all of
these newly independent countries
uh turned democratic there was some
slight back in in
in in some of them but by and large
democracy has held in central europe in
eastern europe
even in some parts of southern europe so
um
there is more democracy around and uh
you know the future of democracy is by
no means assured
we are seeing some very troubling signs
on the horizon
but but democracies are not in full
flight just because you know russia
stopped being
a uh moderate democracy i would say
you know and even the russians know this
despite their
autocratic uh system
there isn't an intellectual or moral
contender
of any import i mean
democracies might degenerate into
dictatorships but
there isn't a ethos of authoritarianism
there isn't an ethos that's well
developed intellectually philosophically
or practically
to um what to
compete with democracy so i mean the
chinese can claim that their system is
more efficient it's like well maybe for
short periods of time now and then but
seems highly unlikely when as the ch as
china became more free
economically it became richer they say
well we can get along we can get away
with not being free
across the board but i suspect that
that's probably just
wrong is that it we're going to see that
that as a
as a comparatively fatal flaw over the
next 30 or 40 years
so but i mean what do you argue if
you're if you're not a liberal democrat
you know in the whole broad sense
ranging from democratic socialist to
ultra conservative let's say but within
the democratic spectrum
well what's outside of that that's
credible intellectually
an alternative system i don't see
anything
russia has a peculiar combination of
nationalism and russian orthodoxy now
that cannot be obviously
uh exported to other countries in the
world it has no purchase on africa for
example latin america
china is an interesting example
they certainly do argue that their
system is superior
but i think that the shine has been
coming off the chinese
model recently with the well it got a
lot more superior when it got a lot more
capitalist it got a lot more superior
they obviously are able to generate a
lot of wealth
they also have a lot more people um but
they are still on average and average
chinese
is much poorer than an average american
it's just that they are dealing with 1.4
billion people
uh but but by letting them be freer
not perhaps politically but economically
the the
the the the chinese economic
institutions stopped being super
extractive
and they became more inclusive and
people could function within them and
produce wealth and keep it and nobody
was coming to take it away from them
at least not with the typical regularity
of a totalitarian regime they were able
to
build a a very prosperous country but
the shine is coming off
not only because of the way that the
chinese have lied about corona
but also because the chinese are
involved in tremendous human rights
abuses
in in in against the eagers
weakers and and places like that it's
very difficult
for any aspiring dictator uh
in africa latin america or europe for
that matter to say
you know china is the model if the the
immediate
retort is aside from those concentration
camps how about that
explain that you well there is their
support for north korea too which we
should never forget
and and and that which is a regime so
rotten that it beggars the imagination
so appalling inexcusable in every
possible way
and the final point i want to make about
china is that
really it is now that china will have to
show
the merit of its own system because
it is one thing to replicate um
to to to replicate
uh say
railways the building of railways and
bridges and
and things like that it is one thing
when you have the benefit of the
technology that's already developed and
what you're doing is picking
low-hanging fruit that's exactly right
whereas now china has to prove
that it can not only
mimic but it can actually produce
new ideas that it can innovate and you
don't
have innovation in country which doesn't
have
freedom of speech which doesn't have
free
exchange of ideas and the ability to
criticize now
now there are specific sectors where
freedom of speech can be allowed so for
example the soviet nuclear and rocket
sciences were allowed a great deal of
experimentation
and internal discussions because
obviously the soviet union was trying to
build as many nuclear
rockets as it possibly could but if you
want to produce
better products um
uh better production processes um new
innovations
on them on a mass sort of societal scale
you have to have
freedom of speech freedom of expression
freedom of communication
and china doesn't have it because of
course the
colorady of the of the of the freedom of
innovation
is that people would be talking about
ideas that the chinese government
doesn't want them to talk about
yeah well and if if you're going to have
a bunch of people who are
talking about ideas and they're going to
be really good at it
they're pretty much nothing can be off
limits
if you get a bunch of creative people
together and they're really being
creative they have to be able to talk
about anything
otherwise their creativity gets
squelched and it's easy to squelch the
creativity
in some sense so and also i think that
creative types are usually
people who are
[Music]
on a broad spectrum of autism and
disagreeability
and uh and you you very s
often see it in in silicon valley but
some research seems to be showing that
and these are the sorts of people
who are going to not hold back these are
the sorts of people who are going to
tell
whatever springs to their mind now
if you're going to put people who
are disagreeable and who speak their
minds
because of the particular traits of
their of their of their psychology if
you're going to put all of them to jail
because they call
chairman she an idiot then you're going
to run out
of of innovative uh people very soon
yeah i'm not so much sure that the
disagreeable element there is
is useful for creativity there's not a
lot of evidence for that but it might be
useful for implementation of creative
ideas
so when i mentioned this this is very
interesting i would like to hear your
view on that when i when i mean
disagreeability
isn't it the ability to say
screw you all i know i'm i'm i'm right
in my ideas
and i'm going to pursue my research
wherever it's going to lead me well
isn't that important well that's what i
mean by implementation though like if
you look at it from a personality
perspective
openness the trait is the one that
governs creativity
and it isn't associated with
agreeableness to any great degree
they're pretty orthogonal
but the issue of to what degree
you need to be disagreeable to implement
effectively
that's that's a different story and i
don't think that data are in on that yet
anyways let's go on let's go on to the
next one let's go on to the long piece
because that's also extraordinarily
important
so long piece basically means is that is
that there are fewer conflicts
um in sin since the end of the second
world war the long-term trends
seems to be toward greater peace we
certainly
no longer have countries declaring war
on each other sending
armies across borders to slaughter that
seems to have almost disappeared
completely that idea
if i remember correctly the last country
to declare war
was the united states on north korea
i could be wrong on that but but i think
i i would love for that to be checked
and maybe you can put a disclaimer on
your video
that i got it completely wrong but i
actually think that happened anyway the
so that no longer happens now countries
still invade other countries
like for example russia invaded ukraine
the little green men who uh who took
uh uh crimea but i think it says
something that even governments
that uh that still still do this sort of
these sorts of things uh do not declare
war
publicly because they are afraid of how
humanity would react to that kind of
uh that kind of uh that kind of activity
and so
most of the conflicts today in fact all
conflicts usually tend to be ethnic and
and civil wars but they are not really
conflicts between
between countries uh wars have become
more uh less deadly
less deadly they are smaller and less
deadly but
please remember this doesn't mean that
you know the
past performance suggests future success
i mean the world is still filled with
nuclear weapons
and so uh but it also seems even on that
front like
it seems like certainly people are
much less convinced that nuclear weapons
will be used purposefully
especially in a mass annihilation than
throughout the 60s 70s and 80s so the
nuclear weapons are still there there's
there's far fewer of them but
imminent war between russia and the
united states
certainly doesn't seem probable in the
same manner that it did
for that entire cold war period up till
the demise of the soviet union
that's right i mean we are down from 40
nuclear warheads per superpower down to
about 3 000.
i'm more worried about nuclear uh about
sorry about
uh accidental yes terrorism
that sort of thing so that's uh what's
what really
worries me much more um but that's a
better worry in some sense than
all-out mass annihilation i mean well
ideally
i mean you have a lot of smart people
who are watching your your podcast
and ideally uh you know
it could be calculated how many nukes
would have to go off
of what strength in order for
there not to be the end of humanity in
other words what is the maximum and if
we could convince
the international powers to bring the
total
maximum number of warheads and their
strength below that level
while still being distributed amongst
nuclear powers you know that then we
could decrease that that
danger even even more
i wonder if that would decrease the uh i
mean one of the things i've thought
reasonably frequently although i'm not
convinced of it is that
nuclear war is so terrifying that it's
actually made us more peaceful
like that terrible threats like the fist
of god there's some places we just can't
go any more
and more and people so far thank god
have
being seemed unwilling to go there
so the terrible threat may have had
benefits
yeah there's a whole branch of
international relations uh
study of international relations which
argues precisely for that you're not
alone
uh there are other people support
supporting your view
um but unfortunately nuclear power
uh nuclear nuclear weapons cannot be
unlearned
and so i'm afraid we are stuck with them
uh and the best that we can do is to
bring the number down to a minimal level
where
superpowers will feel safe without
without destroying the world but
that's just for another for another day
the last one
trend 10 a safer world
and this is death from natural disasters
right so this particular subject can be
looked at
uh from a number of angles one is that
we are in this time of panic
about existential threat to humanity
from climate change
and from the environment and yet in the
last 100 years
the number of people who have died due
to natural disasters has shrunk by 99
the two are incompatible if we are
moving to a world where
millions of people are going to be
destroyed by
you know uh oceans rising or uh
crop failure whatever uh or tsunamis or
earthquakes and whatever
why is it that due to natural disasters
uh that
natural disasters have seen 99
decrease in in human mortality
and um the answer
seems to be that partly we are richer
and therefore we are able to
build uh more sturdy dwellings
um but we are also more technologically
savvy so that we can
uh predict where a hurricane going to
strike and
exactly when so that people can escape
from the path of destruction
and we can also detect
earthquakes underneath the ocean floor
uh
giving people on land more time to move
to higher ground
from a tsunami wave and things like that
so
and we're going to get better and better
at all and we are going to get better
and better at it yeah
so we're richer
by far um
in terms of productivity and quality of
products and
absolute poverty has declined
precipitously
commodity prices have fallen we're not
going to
overpopulate the world in any
cataclysmic sense
everyone has increasingly more than
enough to eat
there's more land for nature and that
trend seems upward
more people are moving to urban areas
and that's advantageous rather than
disadvantageous
there are more democracies and so we're
better governed
we're more peaceful and we're less
likely to die from catastrophes and
i should point out to everyone who's
listening that really only scrapes
the surface of the topics that are
covered in this
remarkable book as i mentioned at the
beginning of this podcast
the authors delve into
comparatively micro trends in detail
discussing such things which i would
love to discuss and perhaps we should
continue this
at some point in the not too distant
future
such things as the precipitous decline
in computational power and that's in its
infancy
um access to electricity uh you mean uh
computational price of computation yeah
yes yes well and and and pure power and
and accessibility and mobile technology
and right
lighting costs and uh decline in
the cost of renewable resources and
clean drinking water and better
sanitation and
um i'm just leafing through the book
internet access and so that's education
and that will get better and better
um
but other than that yeah so so let's
close out with this
[Music]
i've done two three podcasts i think in
the last couple of months
that were aimed at bringing this
information to
to a broader audience um
there seems to some degree to be a
saleability issue or maybe it's just
too soon and like all this good news in
some sense is relatively recent and the
word may just
not have spread um any ideas about
what could be done
to
counter the pessimistic and apocalyptic
narratives that seem to dominate the
public landscape
well you are doing it right now by
interviewing me
i am doing it by having this website
which is made
all the more useful by the fact that we
didn't
come up with this data it's freely
available on many different platforms
uh around the world if you think that
i'm
full of it go to our world in data go to
the world bank go to the imf go to
eurostat that
if if you are interested in that in the
state of the world
there's plenty of data out there that
can show you that
the state of the world is much better
than than it is secondly
um and i'm i'm wondering if uh
if this is even possible but secondly
what if people start understanding more
about their biases about how they
perceive the world
you know that this is obviously done in
colleges and universities
in psychology courses as well as in
biology courses and
things like that but you know it's not
as though
human beings are incapable
of changing their world view based on
evidence we no longer believe
that a sacrifice of a little child will
produce
better harvest so we've learned that
lesson
we no longer believe that throwing a
virgin into a
into a volcano is going to
uh give us military success um
[Music]
we no longer believe in in all sorts of
things that we have taken for granted in
other words we have we have shown that
we are capable of learning and learning
from evidence we have internalized
um that focusing on irrigation
and and fertilization is a better way to
to to produce food than prayer
and that gives me hope that as we move
forward we'll be able to learn
more about um about the rest of the
world internalize not just that
information but also why we are being
pessimistic and negative what do you
think about that
well i'm i'm listening and i'm thinking
it through
i'm also wondering
i would say that learning this material
has made me
has lifted some of the existential
weight
from me things aren't as bad as
they're trumpeted to be in fact they're
quite a bit better
and they're getting better and so we're
doing a better job than we thought
there's more to us than we thought we're
adopting our responsibilities as
stewards of the planet
rapidly we are moving towards improving
everyone's life
it i lived under an apocalyptic
shadow my whole life i mean i don't want
to complain about that too much because
i lived in a very rich place and i had
all sorts of advantages and all of that
but
the apocalyptic narrative was still
extraordinarily powerful and
demoralizing and
it looks to me that there are reasons to
doubt its validity
on all sorts of dimensions and i'm not
sure what that will do to people but
hopefully it'll make us more
optimistic and and positive and
less paranoid and afraid and happier
with who we are and but still willing to
participate in improving the future
and to lift some of the weight off young
people who are constantly being told
that the planet is going to burn to a
cinder in the next 20 years and
and and well that's not happening that's
not happening and and people who push
that
agenda in the newspapers and elsewhere
are completely irresponsible
and cruel but that leads to
that leads to perhaps the the final
point from
from my end like you i have become
much more optimistic uh not much more
happy
in my own personal life once i realized
that
so much around me i didn't have a right
to complain about and i should be
grateful for
i should be grateful for that i'm not
that i'm not a peasant in 17th century
or you know or a and appreciative
of what's brought us here and that's the
key
is that people who do not understand the
crucial role
that political and economic
liberalization
opening inclusion has played
in launching the
industrial revolution uh showing us the
path
the rest of the world a path to to
prosperity if they don't understand
that everything we have is underpinned
by a certain economic and political
system
both of them terribly imperfect terribly
imperfect
but look at the alternative look at the
difference between
chile the extraordinary success of that
country after it embraced free markets
and the collapse of venezuela where
people eat
cats and dogs look at the difference
between botswana
which is a relatively free economy and
its neighbor zimbabwe
where people have experienced
hyperinflation of 96 tillion percent
look at the difference between east and
west germany between
um between the united states and the
ussr look at the difference between
north and south korea
if you really you just called it the
worst
possible regime in the world i think
you're right on that i'm pretty sure
you're right on that
and uh that regime is still out there
if you have a problem with liberal
democracy and and
competitive enterprise fix those
problems
incrementally one by one don't burn down
the system because the alternatives as
you can see
in the world are much worse that is a
great place to end
thank you very much and i'm there's so
many more things we could talk about and
hopefully we'll get an opportunity to do
exactly that some of the micro analysis
because there
are comparative micro analysis because
there's so much data in this book that's
fascinating it's an endless source of
optimistic revelation that's also
realistic
and so i hope many people
buy it and put it on their coffee table
and share it with their friends and
and lift some of the unnecessary burden
of human shame and guilt from their
shoulders
well i'm grateful for that uh
for those kind words about my book i'm
deeply grateful to you for having me on
your show
and i'm delighted that you're doing well
and
hopefully we'll be doing it even better
in the future
[Music]
you